normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government we
have this story from Newsmax one of the
most important stories and I'm gonna I I
don't know I got to make some phone
calls to make this happen bitshoot calls
on rep Jordan to investigate parlor
deplatforming now this is explosive
stuff bitshoot a video hosting social
media platform is calling on Jim Jordan
to investigate the deplatforming of
parlor another social media website
popular with conservatives as part of
his house panel on government weap
weaponization
in a letter to Jordan bitsh sho's Chief
policy officer and former policy Chief
policy parlor Chief policy officer Amy
pikoff wrote that parlor was likely
deplatformed via the same sort of
coordinated effort that were alleged in
the select subcommittee on weaponization
of the federal government's recent
report on the censorship industrial
complex this is explosive and is so far
an allegation but I believe it is fair
to say that the probability lies in them
being correct why did parlor get un
unilaterally removed instantly from all
these companies smeared by the media
instantly all at the exact same time and
it was all fake news they argued that
parlor needed to be removed because
January Sixers were using it to
coordinate despite the fact they
actually used Facebook and despite the
fact the New Evidence that's emerged
shows the police were widely
facilitating what was happening it
stands to reason that the US government
was threatened by the fact that large
amounts of political individuals in the
United States were leaving Twitter for a
rival platform for which they had no
control and we now know thanks to Elon
Musk whose purchase of Twitter is one of
the greatest acts of heroism shout out
Elon Musk because we're learning this
and when he leaked the emails revealing
that so that Twitter with its left
biased was heavily influenced
specifically by the US intelligence
agencies I would be I would be willing
to bet large sums of money parlor was
removed Alex Jones was banned because of
government intervention and I say this
is someone who has proven definitively
right now the US government colluded to
censor me personally we're seeing this I
would like to see Jim Jordan Matt Gates
and anyone else I want to see the
documents relating to parlor because I'm
willing to bet we are going to see
something like an email that goes we're
really concerned about parlor and hey
Apple by the way you do know that
facilitating terrorism is a crime in
this country right and January 6 was an
Insurrection you they used parlor heaven
forbid we accuse you of aiding and
betting terrorism right and then all of
a sudden parlor is gone well and keep in
mind too that the reason parlor got put
taken down was because Amazon web
services shut them down and I think that
they've got a lot of government
contracts they've benefited a lot from
from the App Store well that that is
well that as well but I'm saying that
their actual they had to actually
migrate their servers because AWS
stopped doing business with them because
of the allegations that were fraudulent
from the federal government the federal
government has demonstrated time and
time again that they have their tendrils
into every social media network of any
magnitude whatsoever and parlor came
about kind of had this fast rise that
looked like it might actually be a
competitor for Twitter or something else
and they were like can't have that we
have our we have fought long and hard to
get our hands of the FBI the CIA DHS
everybody else into Facebook Instagram
Twitter every across the board and
they're like we can't have you guys
having another Outlet sorry so we're
going to make it go away and people
think that like this is where I get
pissed is that instead of us just
talking about like I have appreciate
Tim's anger about this because we ought
to be furious do we I mean do we know
what we're actually talking about this
is the land of the free right this is
America right and and we have all we
just accept the fact that every single
thing we do on the Internet is spied on
by the federal government you know when
I was when I was growing up that would
have been laughable and we would have
never even considered it a possibility
now it's a given think about how how far
I almost cussed How Far we' We've
transitioned if if you will remember
when that D dni guy lied to Congress
about spying on the American people yes
yeah it was bu Clapper it was Jes
Clapper I with anger I I kind of feel
like Art of War style when you're angry
don't show it thing cuz I'm beyond like
enraged about the last seven years but I
acting like I'm just happy go-lucky guy
because I really want to change it to
and if you get angry you become a Target
so I don't know if see I'm okay with
being a Target because I want people to
know they're not alone in in their
exasperation like I I'm so exhausted by
the The Tyranny that we languish under
and there's a lot of people out there
that just accept it they just go like it
is what it is I reject that
wholeheartedly it is not it is not
necessary that we suffer this forever we
are I you know I don't go much into
Birthright type of stuff but if there is
a Birthright of every American it is
that we can speak freely we can defend
ourselves you know there's there's a
hand full of like really sanro sank type
of beliefs and ideals that we uphold and
it seems like very few people take that
seriously they look at their politicians
that are constantly infringing upon them
and they accept it they just go it is
what it is Clint you know it's tyranny
that's where we're at that's not okay we
can't live like that if you expect the
America that we knew and loved to
actually sustain itself to to be there
10 20 30 years from now we have to
actually vocalize our our anger towards
the system and actually demand that it
change and I appreciate your kind of you
know Buddhist outlook on it but I really
think that that it there needs to be
some anger demonstrated even if it puts
the sights on me I just don't care I
don't the um it may be that it's
Unstoppable the corruption is
Unstoppable that we need to build
systems that can't be tampered with like
parlor should have been a system that
couldn't be taken down like a
decentralized web Network that like a
mesh Network or something where the
govern's like how do we hit this
whack-a-mole thing it's stoppable I'm
sure could they do it over they would
they would have done so but the truth is
they're gone you know parlor is
basically gone at this point cuz like in
a in a the rise of a social media this
is what's so nefarious about it in the
rise of a social media Network there's
this I mean there's the exponential
growth phase that you have to hit if
you're going to succeed and if you don't
hit it or if you're if you're derailed
mid that uh you know that exponential
rise you're toast so all the all the
federal government has to do from here
on out like like exactly what they're
doing with Tik Tok threatening that
they're going to ban Tik Tok I'm not a
fan of Tik Tok that's not the point you
give them that precedent you allow them
to just shut down one of the most
successful social media apps of all time
maybe the most successful and what do
you think they're going to do from there
well all of a sudden Elon mus acquire
his Twitter got to ban that right
because we already have the president
he's he's allowing he's allowing some
sort of CCP propaganda to be pushed do
you think
on on a long time frame you know 100 200
years do you think that there is is the
possibility that we're going to not have
constant monitoring and and constant you
know the
government or or maybe not even just the
government but constant OverWatch from a
from a large entity because I know that
there's a lot of people that now are
speaking very you know we can't let this
happen and blah blah blah blah blah
Etc because this is still new stuff I
don't think in two generations anyone's
going to even think about not being
monitored all the time well because I
don't think that I don't think the
option I I think that there are
teenagers now that just accept it as
part of reality of course it's a part of
the like it's a part of living in modern
society and I don't see how that's going
to be I don't again like I don't see the
offramp I don't see how how we we we
convin
people that the convenience is not worth
it because that's really what it's what
it's about often times the pendulum
doesn't swing back until the pain is
great enough right and and I feel like
the reason I'm so loud about this stuff
is that you're right Phil that like the
vast majority of young people because
we've got forever like like just barring
some kind of like Extinction event it's
this this problem never goes away for
the rest of the time that there are
human beings well the the surveillance
capacity never goes away but that
doesn't mean that you can't have rules
and regulations that apply to the
government as far as what they're
allowed to do and what criminal
punishment they have to pay if they
violate this how I don't see how we get
any kind of rules or regulations it's
going to happen in some in some
countries it just like do you want it to
be here no no I don't you don't think
it'll happen anywhere on Earth I I don't
think that there's going to be I don't
think that there's any society that
currently has the ability to force their
government to to do anything anymore
damn that's dark you got to build wait
till the AI takes over I know that's
honestly I mean we've had this
conversation Tim like I like once you
get you know chips that can are
implanted in most people's brains and
again these are problems that don't go
away this isn't like oh we'll solve it
this generation and then we don't have
to worry about it in the Next Generation
or the following generation or three
generations down once this Genie comes
is let out of the bottle it is something
that for as long as there is
industrialized commun uh uh you know
modern society this problem does not go
away I see like the law evolving to
computer software code so like instead
of having a law on a paper somewhere
like I hope we're all abiding by that
thing it's actually part of the
structure of our ability to communicate
the laws are written into the way things
work so there's no ability for a
government or fore an entity to violate
the law or the the code of the system
you're you're you're you're neglecting
Pirates you're neglecting to think about
real meat machines that don't want it's
kind of like saying like hey send me
some send me an ice cream cone on
Twitter you can't because it can only
send certain types of things because the
code is such that only certain types of
things can be transmitted so if that's
your system you can like you know
observing from the outside isn't part of
that code system considering the
conversation that we've had so far
tonight talking about what was done to
parlor what makes you think that that
will ever be a possibility what what
benefit how like why would the people
that currently control the levers of
power why would they allow that because
right now I think that there's an that
there's the people that the powers that
be have enough control where I think
it's already too late I think you could
still build it using like blockchain
technology and have decentralized yeah I
don't think I don't I think that I think
that it it'll take it would take uh the
will I think that that people don't have
the will to push back against it because
that's what I'm working
on modern society is so convenient your
average kids don't know what they like
that we see Tik toks and we make jokes
about Tik toks all the time of of kids
that don't have any idea how Society
Works gen Z 2021 80% supporting same-sex
marriage 2023 65% I'm not making a moral
statement I'm saying opinions shift
dramatically and things could change
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net